♪ Être ici ♪
- C'est à Saint-Venant-
de-Paquette, un village
de 98 habitants situé en Estrie,
que se trouve le jardin
de Richard Séguin. Le lieu
est tellement inspirtt
qu'il y vit depuis 50 ans
avec sa conjointe.
RICHARD SÉGUIN,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Faudrait pas je déménage,
j'ai trop de choses. Mais c'est
un fait que Marthe et moi,
on était... on se sent à l'aise,
on se sent... Puis, c'est
un équilibre incroyable pour
moi, et puis, bien, pour nous
deux, quand on fait
ce métier-là.
♪ Rien n'est terminé ♪
- Il y a d'ailleurs beaucoup
de Saint-Venant, sur le nouvel
album de Richard Séguin
intitulé "Les liens, les lieux".
Sa poésie, il la met au service
de Dame Nature.
- Oui, il est question de liens,
liens avec la famille,
liens avec la nature,
liliens avec les amitiés,
liens avec le village comme tel.
Et puis, au niveau des lieux,
c'est l'ancrage du territoire.
♪ Le garage de mon père ♪
- Parmi les 10 nouvelles
chansons, il y a en une
pour son père, "Le garage",
et pour sa mère, il a écrit
"Tout près des trembles".
♪ Tout près des trembles ♪
- J'avais jamais composé
de chanson pour ma mère.
Et on lui doit beaucoup,
dans la famille, parce que
c'est elle q a a introduit
la culture dans la maison.
C'est elle qui a fait qu'il y
avait des livres. Elle a fait
en sorte qu'il y avait un piano.
Puis, c'est après coup
qun n se rend compte: Eille,
ces livres-là, c'est elle qui
a pensé à nous...
♪ Le temple où est son coeur ♪
- Richard Séguin a aussi écrit
une chanson pour son ami Florent
Vollant, et il s'est entouré
de nombreux collaborateurs,
dont l'écrivnene Hélène Dorion.
- Le premier texte qui ouvre
l'album, c'est son écriture,
et ça dit "I"Il est déjà minuit
dans la forêt du monde.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a trahi
pour que l'orage gronde?"
Juste là, c'est la lucidité
de s'apercevoir qu'on est
dans une époque qui peut être
chaotique avec les changements
climatiques.
♪ Il y a de ces clairières ♪
- Richard Séguin s'apprête
à quitter Saint-Venant,
momentanément, pour une tournée
de 80 concerts qui l'amènera
aux quatre coins du Québec.
Et c'est la grande forme.
- Bien, parce que Saint-Venant,
c'est Jouvence.
(rires)
Viens-t'en ici, tu vas voir!
Mais je suis content
qu'à mon âge, je puisse encore
faire des chansons. Un défi
à la grande faucheuse...
(rire)
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada,
à Saint-Venant-de-Paquett